a lot of captain america's mcu storyline
was taken straight from the comics
but that doesn't mean all of his comic
stories ended up in the mcu
for better or worse these are some of
the most notable details and stories
that the marvel movie universe left
behind
in the marvel cinematic universe the
avengers are cap's one and only super
team
he does hang out with the howling
commandos in world war ii
but that's more just a nickname for a
military unit than anything else
in the comics however steve actually
joins a super-powered group during the
war
deep in the midst of the fight against
nazi germany cap forms a team with the
submariner and the original human torch
to save british prime minister winston
churchill from the nazi villain
masterman when they decide to stay
together
churchill suggests the name the invaders
the group that eventually would be
called the invaders were actually first
introduced as a team in a time traveling
issue of the avengers
in which earth's mightiest heroes
surprise opponents are revealed to be
the greatest
superheroes of world war ii over time
the team adds bucky
and torches flame-powered ward toro the
mongoose blood-powered speedster the
whizzer and his wife miss america
also become full members the team also
includes british heroes like
union jack and his sister spitfire who
gets her powers when the human torch
gives her a blood transfusion
there are a couple of dozen more active
superheroes during world war two too
so if marvel ever decides to do another
movie set during the war
they'd have no shortage of characters to
choose from or team names
as the original version of the invaders
was called the all winners
squad on second thought invaders works
just fine
after the events of captain america's
civil war cap gives up his uniform and
goes underground
in the comics however steve rogers has
quit being captain america several times
the first and most famous instance comes
when cap goes up against an evil
organization called
the secret empire that had been using a
disinformation campaign to discredit him
using the particularly imaginative alias
of roger stevens
capp goes undercover in an effort to
track down their leader
and the trail soon leads to washington
the leader of the secret empire number
one
then emerges from a flying saucer before
being defeated by
cap to cap surprise number one runs into
the white house
while he isn't mentioned by name in the
comic writer steve englehart later
confirmed that number one was
in fact president richard nixon nixon
then kills himself before cap can
apprehend him
and a disillusioned cap retires to the
delight of girlfriend sharon carter and
pretty much no one else in an effort to
get capped to remember how much he liked
being a superhero
hawkeye shows up with a disguise and a
weird fake accent
when steve tells him he won't be captain
america anymore hawkeye gives him some
advice
adopt a new identity instead so cap puts
his design skills to good use
and reinvents himself as nomad the man
without a country
before long however steve becomes cap
again when the red skull returns to
wreak havoc
after that things pretty much go back to
normal
in the mcu cap has been lucky enough to
be spared the indignity of a common rite
of passage for long-running superheroes
losing his powers in the comics however
cap has had no such luck
in captain america number 355 cap gets a
phone call from his ex-girlfriend
bernie rosenthal telling him that her
younger sister had gone missing
he then realizes that members of his
nationwide teen informant network had
befallen the same fate
trying to find a way to go undercover
cap asks the eternal known as
cersei to turn him into a 15 year old
version of himself
but when he is de-aged he loses the
effects of the super soldier serum
infusion that made him captain america
in the first place cap is usually one to
have a pretty good plan in place for
stuff like this
this was not one of those occasions
powerless and shieldless he wanders over
to port authority and basically blunders
his way
into reaching his goal a camp for kids
that is actually a nihilistic
death cult around the same time he ends
up being attacked by his old enemies
scarborough and mother knight and the
transformation trigger turns out to be
the 50th time cap gets punched
then when it seems like he's about to be
beaten to a pulp
he turns back into his normal self
defeats the villains
and tells the kids at the camp to stay
in school and obey their parents
that's captain america all right
how many more of these being a kid isn't
the only indignity cap has suffered in
the comics
like any good superhero he has also
occasionally been turned into a
full-blown monster
joining an all-star wolf lineup captain
america is transformed into a werewolf
by
nightshade who is building a werewolf
army for a man named
dredmund which includes other wolf-based
superheroes such as
wolf spain farrell and man wolf to this
end
cap is captured and injected with
werewolf serum
but it turns out the super soldier serum
allows him to retain control of his wolf
form
this enables him to not only beat up a
whole lot of bad guys
but also use his natural leadership
skills to help convince the werewolves
to fight with him
and become cap's own wolf pack after
that a bunch of nonsense happens
including dredman becoming the star wolf
and cable showing up for some reason but
things get turned around when man wolf
injects nightshade with her own
serum this motivates her to develop an
antidote
putting an end to cap's lycanthropic
adventures
but that's not the end of steve rogers
many magical mutations
years later cap is kidnapped by the
jackal during the spider island
storyline
and is transformed into the monstrous
spider king
a slave of the spider queen the spider
king is implanted with thousands of eggs
when these eggs hatch the resulting
spiders are then supposed to infect
anyone they bite
and turn them into a spider mutate under
the spider queen's control
cap is eventually defeated by venom who
takes him to a facility for a cure
after this steve helps lead the
resistance against the arachnid menace
and brings them down once and for all
evacuate the city engage all defenses
and get this man shield
everyone knows captain america is
basically half shield half man
and the marvel movies have even seen him
use a few variants on the classic design
but in the comics he once ended up with
a very different shield than
any scene in the mcu during one of his
many battles against
evil cap's seemingly indestructible
shield is affected by
a vibranium virus and torn to pieces
he uses his original triangular shield
for a while but that also ends up being
destroyed
so naturally sharon carter ends up
giving him an energy shield to use
while nothing could ever replace the
strong light and highly balanced shield
that was practically an extension of his
own body
the energy shield nonetheless comes in
pretty handy
and cap uses it on a number of his
adventures years later
after steve rogers hands over the
captain america mantle to bucky barnes
he uses a different energy shield for
his adventures this one is comprised of
zero point
energy which allows him to throw it
strike his enemies and then dissipate it
into the air
a new one is then automatically
generated obviously
nothing can really replace the original
but still pretty cool right
the aftermath of the 911 attacks was a
grim and confusing time for the united
states
and the same was true for captain
america in the mcu however
cap didn't get revived until long after
that tragedy took place
rebooting as part of the marvel knights
brand the first issue of a newly
relaunched captain america series
finds cap sifting through the wreckage
of 9 11. nick fury had tasked him to
track down the culprits but cap prefers
to stay as part of the rescue operations
that changes however when terrorists
take the american town of centerville
hostage cap infiltrates the town and
attacks the mastermind of the crisis
a terrorist named al tariq to his credit
the story does try to keep things as
balanced as possible
for example cap saves an arab-american
youth earlier in the issue from a gang
that was threatening to
kill him as a misguided attempt at
revenge for 9 11.
similarly the children that al tariq has
strapped bombs to are all victims of
unexploded landmines
when they realize they're being used
they help cap diffuse the bombs attached
to the citizens of centerville
who are trapped together in a church
eventually
cap grew is suspicious when he sees that
al tariq is wearing a piece of
technology called a cat tag
that is normally used to monitor vital
signs fury is characteristically shifty
when confronted about this
and capp soon learns that a villain who
was affected by the cold war was
planning to kill every american who was
wearing one
inevitably captain america defeats this
new bad guy
and saves the day in the mcu cap and his
arch enemy the red skull fight just a
couple of times in world war
ii in the comics however the red skull
clashes with captain america
on many occasions until they engage in a
final showdown near the end of the war
cap barely escapes the resulting
explosion but the red skull is trapped
in a building
and exposed to gases that put him in a
state of suspended animation
after the skull is revived from
suspended animation he proves to be a
lethal nuisance for years
he swipes the cosmic cube aka the
tesseract
and almost destroys cap with it he teams
up with adolf hitler
in his hate monger guys then later traps
him in the cube
he also activates sleeper robots to hunt
down cap
because at that point why not later the
red skull becomes ahead of a commission
that forces cap to give up his identity
and begins funding both anarchist and
fascist organizations
along the way he gets his head handed to
him by both magneto
and kingpin on two separate occasions
becomes secretary of defense
and eventually has cap assassinated
after the events of civil war
in a last-ditch attempt to take over his
body spoiler alert
it doesn't work in the mcu steve rogers
is the one and only american to have
received the genuine super soldier serum
in the comics however there have been
many men who have been given a variation
of the serum
as the government tried desperately to
develop an army of super soldiers
one of these men is isaiah bradley who
was drafted into world war
ii shortly after getting married and
quickly conscripted into an experiment
along with 300 other black men
in an effort to recreate the serum after
undergoing a series of gruesome and
highly unethical experiments
the survivors become covert soldiers
used on dangerous black ops missions
bradley is later sent on a suicide
mission to kill a nazi scientist trying
to develop a super soldier formula of
his own
bradley is successful in this mission
but is ultimately captured by the nazis
eventually he escapes thanks to the
efforts of some local resistance heroes
but he is then immediately
court-martialed and imprisoned upon his
return to the us
because he had stolen a captain america
outfit and shield
bradley then ends up in prison for
nearly two decades
and his mind starts to decay thanks to
the faulty nature of his super serum
over the years bradley quietly receives
visitors who arrive
to pay their respects to the black
captain america his son
josiah and his grandson eli both spent
time as heroes
with eli forming the young avengers and
finally once he learns of bradley's
existence
steve rogers himself stops by his home
to pay his respects
to this long forgotten hero check out
one of our newest videos
right here plus even more looper videos
about your favorite movies are coming
soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]